Salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors.
Aujourd'hui, on est toujours avec Wim
et Danny, on est au bord du canal.
Regardez
C'est pas un canal, c'est un petit ruisseau
qu'on va sonder
Elle est remplie de vase.
Mais c'est un canal
parce qu'il n'y a pas de courant.
Alors sur Google Maps,
ça s'appelle rivières ou ruisseaux,
mais si Quentin appelle ça un canal...
Mais l'avantage, c'est que ça passe
sous la route et une route très passante.
Il y a aussi une maison abandonnée là,
qui était squatée
C'est ça et aujourd'hui,
on n'a pas pris de cordes.
On a pris nos perches
parce qu'on va aller dans l'eau
et on a appelé Wim,
qui est un professionnel de ça.
Oui, vous avez sa chaîne qui s'affiche ici
Ouais, n'hésitez pas à voir sa chaîne.
Regardez, il est plus grand que nous,
ça lui permet d'aller plus loin aussi
dans les ruisseaux.
Et il ne comprend rien du tout de tout ce qu'on dit alors regardez le look
qu'il a avec son bonnet. OK.
Allez, on attaque tout de suite. On a déjà une trouvaille à peine
il vient d'arriver dans l'eau.
Danny
C’est peut être un scooter
Oh Ok
là
Il y a de l’huile
Je pense à un vélo
OK, il y a de l'essence
Peut être une moto
Un scooter.
Un scooter super,  Baptiste c'est
un bon début
je vais aller chercher une corde.
On va l'attacher
et on va le sortir de l'eau.
On envoie les Hollandais dans l'eau
comme ça.
Nous, on se mouille pas.
Ils travaillent pour nous.
L'autre jour à Agen
on était à cinq pour tirer un scooter,
donc j'espère qu'on va arriver à quatre.
Mais il a l'air plus petit.
Oui il est plus petit
et on a des des costauds avec nous
Des pêcheurs à l'aimant expérimentés
On s'échauffe.
C'est lourd
Vous savez, c'est un un beau bébé.
Avec deux cordes et deux personnes.
Ça devrait le faire. Mais de peu
il n'y a pas la plaque
1,2,3
Félicitations
Bien
Première trouvaille de la journée
La meilleure façon de commencer la journée,
Super
Il a été jeté il y a trois ans
Il y a 10 ans
Il est beau
Si vous savez quel modèle c'est en commentaires
On peut accélérer
Ca fonctionne
L’aiguille indique le Nord
rasta tu veux y aller aussi ?
rasta
Ça y est, on attaque la pêche.
ça vient d'un bateau
On dirait un gouvernail
C'est le gouvernail du bateau
entre Cool week end qui date à la va.
On peut garder ça
C'est le gouvernail d'un bateau
C'est vraiment drôle,
on s'enfonce dans la vase
C'est tout moue, vraiment très drôle sensation
J’ai trouvé une partie, ce n’est pas si lourd
Tu vois, Danny
Quentin a un deuxième scooter peut être ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils vont remonter ?
Il est remplie de vase
C’est un caddie de supermarché
Un caddie
Ah non c'est pas un caddie
C’est pour pêcher les poissons
Pour les poissons.
OK donc c'est un matériel de pêcheur.
C’est un grand volant
Il vient peut-être d'un camion
Sympa
J'ai l'impression de descendre l'Amazonie
comme Mike Horn.
Il y a un truc
Ok moi aussi j'en ai un
Deux roues en même temps.
OK, on va continuer à nettoyer la rivière,
c'est mieux que rien.
Donc deux autres pneus.
un autre. J'en ai un autre.
Y a pas grand chose.
On va aller un peu plus sous le pont
et on va voir ce qu'on arrive à trouver.
Oh non Rasta
Rasta tu vas tomber
Vien si tu veux nager, mais tu vas tomber là
Qu'est ce que tu fais, Baptiste ?
Rasta.
Qu'est ce que tu fais à Baptiste.
Une pièce
Wim a trouvé des pièces
J’avais déjà celle là mais j’en ai trouvé une autre
Ok
peut-être qu'il y a une caisse de monnaie
Va chercher !
Viens Rasta
Avec Tonton Wim.
Rastaaaaa
Il est tout mignon
Bon, on trouve rien,
mais y en a un qui se régale.
Pas vrai ?
Rasta
C'est pas de la maltraitance animale.
C'est lui qui voulait venir dans l'eau
Rasta impassible face à l'agresseur.
Ils ne te font pas peur ?
Ils sont que 4 tu risques rien.
T'es le plus fort.
Oui, tu vas leur casser la gueule.
Wouf wouf (aboiements en français)
Wim est en plein travail.
Que penses tu de ce spot ?
C’est un bon spot mais je ne sent rien pour l’instant
On va voir
On va commencer ici à voir ce qu'on trouve.
Il y a énormément de vases
ça vient d'une mobylette ça
Ok
Un crochet.
c'est un pied de biche cassé
C'est bon signe
Regarde une disqueuse
Elle ne fonctionne plus
Dommage
C’est un bon début
Bon spot
C’est pour ouvrir les coffres forts
Maintenant
Où est le coffre ?
je le cherche
Allez, il y a tout pour ouvrir le coffre fort
maintenant on va le trouver
Qu'est ce que tu fais là ?
Allez, on va regarder sous les ponts
Encore un pneu
Belle trouvaille.
J'essaie de passer avec la perche.
D'abord
Il y a moins de vase sous les ponts
ça a déjà été nettoyé.
Bonjour
C’est plus profond ici
J'ai une cuillère
Une petite cuillère
Toute propre.
Tiens
Une partie de voiture
L'aimant est coincé à l'intérieur.
ça le fait rire
Alors là, c'est compliqué.
On va essayer de tirer
Oh, et les aimants marchent bien.
C’est de cette façon qu’il faut faire
Il n'y a pas grand chose sous le pont,
mais on s'amuse bien.
On va traverser de l'autre côté
le temps de visser de nouveau l'aimant
Oh oh là.
C'est les boites qui viennent des voitures
Les boîtes avec les triangles de signalisation
Parfait le triangle
Le lustre avec les
les pales qui tournent pour rafraîchir.
Hop !
Super, on continue.
C'est du bois
Non, c'est pas du bois,
c'est de l'aluminium
J'ai quelque chose
Wim et Danny sont encore là bas.
Moi j'ai avancé et j'ai trouvé un Asus.
Regardez comme il est beau
Ouaah l'état du truc !
ça pue
Intel Core 2
Windows 7
Génial !
On peut rechercher Pêcheur de Trésors
Wim’s Treasure Adventures
Un pot d’échappement ?
Un gros pot d'échappement
Il va nous fatiguer celui-là
Belle dépollution. Bien joué
un vélo.
Chez Décathlon.
Oui il vient du magasin Decathlon
C'est un vélo sans selle.
Les préférés de Quentin
J’espère que ce n’est pas de la merde dedans
OK. Un sac.
Un médicament ?
Un médicament
Il n'y a rien d'autre
Il y a un rocher
Médicaments et...
Seulement des cachets...
Quel type de médicaments ?
Doliprane
C’est illégal ? - Non c’est légal
C’est étonnant
Ca n’a aucun sens
Non. Non, non, je n'ai pas voulu avoir.
Mais c’est sorti de l’eau
La boîte de chocolats.
À la santé.
Il y a des bijoux mais ils sont collés
Il y en a encore ici
Alors moi, j'ai
trouvé une pièce de la reine Elizabeth 2
Oui c'est la reine
Coucou Rasta
Un bout de boucles d'oreilles.
C'est de l'or ou pas ?
Je ne pense pas que ce soit de l'or
Serviettes hygiénique ça,  désolé.
Queen Elizabeth
Pas évident.
On n'a pas assez pieds c'est trop profond
J'ai quelque chose, mais...
J’ai quelque chose dans les rochers, je crois que c’est un cadre de moto
J’ai besoin d’aide
J’ai la selle
Le siege
Ah un vélo, d'accord !
Joli, ça c'est un sanglier
C'est un sanglier
Pas un cochon, un cochon sauvage
Ahh
C'est la fin de la vidéo.
Regardez tout ce qu'on a pêché
aujourd'hui.
Joli scooter.
On s'attendait à plus de choses sous ce pont,
mais bon, tant mieux c'était propre
C'était sympa quand même.
Encore un grand merci à Wim et Danny qui sont
venus nous rejoindre pour cet événement
et qui nous ont appris la pêche
avec la perche.
D'ailleurs,
si vous voulez trouver une perche,
elle vient du site de maison
de la détection.
Vous avez -5% sur tout le site
avec le code promo PECHEURDETRESORS
Et nous,
on vous dit à la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à l'aimant
Pensez à visiter la chaîne de Wim qui est en description.
Il s'est lancé,
ils ont trouvé des dingueries
Vous le savez,
il est avec nous sur la vidéo à Bruxelles.
Il pêche beaucoup en Belgique, mais aussi
aux Pays-Bas, à Amsterdam notamment.
En vous affichez la vidéo à Bruxelles
en fin de vidéo ici
Et maintenant bonne douche !